in this solar system
if the cops and the bounty hunters don't
get you the syndicate will
there's no happy ending here
spoken like a man who's never been in
love
i was
what happened
i was dreaming
um i want to know if you guys know
what's better than a buddy cop series
a bounty bounty hunting cowboy bebop
trio you guys are amazing in this series
i love the chemistry oh my gosh the
doggies i love the dog in the uh
in the frame
where's the dog over right there beside
you
we like your little dog
it looks like a funeral picture
spoiler alert no it's not actually it's
actually not
oh my gosh you guys i have i'm such a if
you can tell i'm such a fan of this
series and what you guys did with it in
the world that it creates i'm going to
start with you john this is not your
first rodeo to use a catchphrase um and
this is such a beloved property by fans
but what i love is number one you have
these great one-liners like my favorite
line in the whole thing is that's
between me and the eel
mindy kaling has tweeted about your hair
so it's already iconic how many hours in
the hair chair were you but also just
creating spike and creating him
for the fans who love the anime series
but making it making him your own
uh a lot there um yeah it was uh it was
daunting
because i was aware that this was an
iconic character and people were going
to
uh
care uh deeply about how it was
portrayed so i wanted to write by them
but it was also you know it's a push and
pull because you want to feel ownership
yourself and you want to feel free and
you want to have fun and you want to you
know on a day-to-day basis you don't
want to feel that burden
um you don't want it to interpret it as
a burden you know what i'm saying so it
was both
wanting to do right by them and also
wanting to
uh be feel free in the role and so it
was definitely
balancing those two things uh was was
key
to to playing this role how do you get
your caller to stay up and not go down
did you ever have to stop a take for
that reason that the caller flipped down
or were they sort of starched up it had
no crease it was always meant to beat up
i don't know if it was ever down
so
it didn't seem like it mustafa um
number one talk talk to me about the
fact that you sort of have this duality
to your character um you have the
relationship with spike but then you're
also this family guy and i loved the
sort of storyline with sally the doll
was
stuff of legends so talk about sort of
creating that chemistry between the two
of you but did you also have something
as a kid that you always wanted it was
always sold out and you never got
yes
i will answer the latter question
voltron the metal one
um i mean it was not just sold out it
was way too expensive for a kid um i i
should buy one matter of fact at the end
of the day i'm gonna get on amazon but
uh developing the character i mean it
was just about you know
the natural dynamic is pulling spike off
the ledge you know which gave me so much
to do
um
and so like that that was pretty easy
because like he's he's antithetical to
me so there's always going to be this
back and forth bickering friction um but
at the same time there's love so there's
going to be connection to make it go
ongoing um and i think that you know we
did that daniella my favorite episode is
actually episode four and i really think
that's because that's when you all sort
of become this amazing trio if you can
talk a little bit about that chemistry
creating that chemistry and then i think
i heard something about a boot camp and
how was the boot camp um how did that go
down who's actually the coolest because
it's such a cool series i'm not the
coolest wait like who's the coolest in
boot camp it's definitely not me i think
the coolest in boot camp is alex hassell
and i'll tell you why because we all
thought we were hot we were trying moves
actually very athletically
athletically gifted but i just remember
alex saying like that he was had like so
much wine and beer and chips coming from
london and but he was a ballet dancer so
like when he would do a kick it would
just happen and i deeply resented him
for that
oh he's he's intense i think alex and
moo dominate the boot camp the boot camp
atlanta wasn't no schmoe either no she
wasn't actually yeah
you're giving everybody else credit not
yourself like coffee
[Laughter]
um but if you talk if you can talk a
little bit about that sort of that
chemistry between the three of you
because it is pretty incredible you all
bring such different elements together
and daniella truly you i when i watched
you in the role i was like nobody else
could have played this role like she did
like you're amazing in it thank you
thank you i really appreciate that
um i think uh we got to spend a ton of
time with each other this show was i
think the hardest thing that
we had ever done and
um i also think
you know keeping the show through
the pandemic and through breaks and then
training we just went through a lot
together and i do think that that bonded
us
what do you say fellas
you want to team up
i was thinking a 60-40 split
going my way of course
do not shoot her
please no it's so good to see you both
you're both uh with sort of redhead
brunette now what is your relationship
like with bleach after shooting the
series wigs was it wigs or was it bleach
luckily luckily it was wigs yeah i am
playing but not quite that much
was it because of the series there was
this is nice yeah right i was a 15 year
old before
oh my gosh well it's great to see you
both i do as you can tell i dove right
into this i love this series for the
fact that number one it's based on a
property that is so beloved but also 140
sets or something like that like no two
scenes are the same but for each of you
um i'll start with you alex what from
the series like did you draw on and how
did you sort of how did you keep that in
mind but then create your own thing for
this series
yeah that's a great question i guess we
ended up taking that um the vicious in
the anime is kind of the the
vicious
that the person inside would like to be
perceived as that he would like to be
seen as this very hard cold sartorially
very elegant poised um
you know terrifying person uh but that i
think what the show our version sort of
fleshed out was all of the the beating
heart underneath and the vulnerability
and the damage um and the kind of pain
that was underneath so it was trying to
to yeah explore those two sides i guess
wow um elena for you i mean julia
there's much more of her in the series
than in the original so how did you get
to sort of flesh out something new um
well the the thing from the anime that i
really um took with me was the duality
of the character i really felt like
you know you either see her through the
memories of spike so she's you know it's
a perception and then when you actually
see her in real time on anime she's like
you know she's running around shooting a
gun like she's a really different person
and so it was taking that into the live
action and building on that and going
okay well here is the woman that these
men i think both of them perceive her to
be this kind of angelic
maternal person and then there's the
real julia which is you know somebody
who
who is very very capable of of
manipulation and taking care of herself
um and that was really the the thing
that i kept in mind she's extremely
shrewd isn't she in a way that i think
the vicious is not really aware of until
until it's too late one thing i also
noticed like because there's so many
different genres like there's a very
neo-noir element and almost like a
romantic a romanticism to both of your
characters and your relationship do you
play that as actors or like because your
voices are also very different in the
series from actually talking to you
right now there's definitely like a kind
of gothic element to
you know our scenes especially in our
penthouse um
there's definitely one
one scene i can't remember i had to
stride around you know i'm wearing all
black
or something and the camera sort of
pushed right into me as i said something
like i'm going to tear the temple down
to the ground or something and i sort of
did a version of it it was like yeah
that's not enough i think i need to you
know go bigger on it and kind of you
know really be you know go god of gothic
on it yeah yeah you really have to keep
the the genre in mind when you're doing
something like this yeah sometimes you
might land on something go oh god is
this overacting is this too much but
then you really have to consider the
world and consider the other half of the
show which we're not really a part of
during season one so it's really like we
totally need to be on the same page
you mentioned the katana talk about the
katana and the training behind working
with
that yeah the training was
incredibly intense so intense in fact
that one of the early sessions i puked
um that i
hope we were pushed so or i sort of
pushed myself so hard in terms of
getting really fit
that i ended up i ended up throwing up
all over the floor
that was only the one time that's the
dedication the amount of dedication that
i have to the role of vision but um then
aside from mopping that up there was a
great deal of work with the stunt team
this amazing stunt team of martial
artists world-class martial artists that
really puts me through my paces it was
very important to me to get to do as
much of the fighting as i could in you
know when in the eventual um
when we were filming it and i'm very
proud to say that i think 98
of it is me um and the reason thank you
the reason i wanted to do that is
one it's really really good fun uh but
also vicious is so important to him to
be so precise with his sword to be so
intimidating um it seemed like the real
center of his character so i needed to
have some command i felt um over that
and yeah it was really important to the
to me and to the character
[Music]
what the actual
i suited up for this because i love this
series so much and i love what you did
with it it doesn't feel like anything
else out there um and what i loved
hearing was that you were actually
nervous to take on this property because
it is so iconic and it's a cult classic
and i thought that showed real humility
um so just talk me through that um i
heard like the crew watched the original
anime series together on set
bringing those elements
and then also making it your own
yeah well uh a little dose of fear is uh
always good to keep you honest um
and uh i think overconfidence in taking
on a project like this um
wouldn't have resulted in what we did
um it's iconic and it's it's an
incredible sandbox to get to play in and
for me the most important thing the the
the directive the thesis for the season
was
we must live in the spirit of the anime
we must look at the choices that were
made and make our choices but at a lot
of times if it ain't broke don't fix it
that prop was in the anime and it looked
pretty good like why are we trying to
fix it like let's take the win
um and then there were other areas where
we knew that we needed to expand the
canon and from that we did real deep
forensic work
on the canon on the anime to really mine
every morsel of information that we
could get not only from the anime itself
but the inspirations
in which to craft our narrative that we
were going to tell i i love that that
you say you know if it's not broke don't
fix it because i wish some of some other
franchises would pay attention to that
advice i'll move on from that um i think
i read something like 140 different sets
and i'm wondering i don't know if that
was the right number or not
but what i liked about it is that there
i don't think i saw a scene repeated
twice or a set that felt like repeated
twice really so talk about that
like the camera angles are also really
cool and i think they paid homage
and the fact that you have so many
walk-on roles like so many actors that
probably came in for one scene and
they're all so colorful so just building
that world yeah oh my god we did we had
like the cast of ben hur it was uh
enormous um and yes we did we did shoot
a million sets um
and all of those were were builds right
all of those were worlds that we had to
create and it was exciting because what
i love about bebop from the anime and i
feel i really was important to capture
was sort of like the non-dystopian
version of the future albeit it's a
cowboy show and life is cheap and
corporations are corrupt and the cops
are criminals
it's still not dystopian
and we represent a world that has a
nostalgia to the world that we live in
and i think that that relatability helps
tell the stories
but every one of those sets to walk onto
was outstanding um even things were in a
normal show you would go and rent a bar
and shoot a scene in a bar
we would be like i don't know that bar
is not bebop enough we gotta we gotta
bebop that out so let's just build our
own bar
um and i think it it really serves the
style of the show incredibly well you
know the snl more cowbell you're like
more bebop please yeah
um talk about the fact that yoko
came on and worked on so much of the
music
for the series how that shaped it
because i really think the music is like
another character watching it you really
feel that music
huge uh the the sonic identity of cowboy
bebop the anime is is unparalleled
so when yoko said like let's do it and
she and i sat down and we chatted about
the characters and the storytelling and
the arcs and the scripts and the kinds
of scenes um
it was it was just magnificent she's a
true talent um she's a pure musician in
the most profound way possible um and uh
what a joy to to work with her and um
to have those jazzy licks
those western riffs those underbellies
of action
it it just it gives the show such an
incredible identity
all right tell me your favorite easter
egg
there's a really good easter egg it's
not a hard one it's actually pretty
obvious
um that the set decorator and i got into
a big fight about um because i didn't
want it and she wanted it and she
demanded it and i was like you can't
have it and then i just finally uh
gave in in episode four my favorite
episode oh awesome
so i will i will leave it at that and
someone will find out what that easter
egg is i'm already thinking ahead to
season two
what would you like to build on in
season two if given the opportunity
i think that to me the the best part
about season one
was
looking at who these characters were
how their pasts
um caught up and how they responded to
them
and i think season two will have an
interesting sort of continuation of
building out these characters so to me i
always sort of start from the
who are they and what is their journey
going to be and where do i want to see
them end up this year and then once i
know that
how do i retrofit the journey to get
them there
because
part of what i think is important about
these characters
is that they often make the poorest
choice they could make for themselves in
any given moment but i think that's part
of their charm is that they tend to go
left when going right would just be the
easy path and that's part of the fun of
it so to be able to continue on that
path would be amazing one last question
you can just tell me yes or no will
spike be more hungry or less hungry in
season two he's very hungry oh
guy is always hungry
you